can you speak to this term occupation in
Gaza because the people that say it is
not an occupation say that Israeli
troops have been pulled out from there
before October 7th for many years yeah
and to you it still is a deao occupation
Israel doesn't get to set the terms and
then Define them uh it is an occupation
according to any uh legal standard
international legal standard Israel
controls the movement of everyone in
Gaza it controls the air and the Seas uh
it controls the ability to import or
export the people that live in Gaza and
the people that live in the West Bank
the
Palestinians have had their identity
stolen from them so there's the freedom
of movement there is the freedom of
thriving there is self-determination all
of that has been stolen from the people
of Gaza there's no airport in Gaza that
was destroyed by Israel as well uh it is
an occupation uh at at at every level
and by any meaningful legal
determination